i'm just [ __ ] chilling and uh i
wanted to talk to you guys about
um let's see if i got this here about
this
uh this is
absolutely [ __ ] insane
here's another cool thing i love about
journaling
if you ever
go to bed at night you start thinking
about all the stuff you got to do the
next day and it gets kind of
intimidating and your brain starts going
you're having trouble getting to sleep
because you're like oh yeah i got to do
this this this and this how am i going
to remember wait wait how's my day going
to flow sure about the minute you wake
up in the morning and you're like oh
yeah i've got to do this just
write it down oh the night before
make it long
put fun stuff on there too like have my
first cup of coffee
hug my life
uh um call a friend
uh um wear my favorite t-shirt put fun
easy stuff on there because what's fun
is the more things you get to cross off
the next day did it done
done done
the more we feel like we we accomplished
and we did but write the list down and
you'll have so much fun crossing them up
i've got 26 things to do today
i've already crossed off seven
i got 19 more to go and it's not even 10
a.m
here's another cool thing dude what what
what man hey guy
you okay
hey guy oh just do it to do list
oh you didn't invent it
you know what you can do man you know
you do you get four tires and you just
put them on a plank man you just put
them on a plank get an engine going and
you just [ __ ]
take it could take you anywhere you know
that that's a car you just take a car
and you just take a car somewhere you go
somewhere you just do that man you can
go to the supermarket you can just drive
around
you didn't invent a car
you just take a list you make a list put
fun things on there that's when it
really started devolving to me put fun
things on there man have a cup of coffee
hug my
wife
got in such an argument with his wife
earlier that's why he [ __ ] paused hug
my
wife
wear my favorite t-shirt imagine if you
saw somebody's to-do list on the fridge
you were hanging out with them and then
you just saw like number three was
wear my favorite t-shirt you'd be like
oh dude
dude that's a that's not something you
just got dressed
that's not something to do it's gonna
get done anyway he did a [ __ ]
just like crossing [ __ ] out
you know what i should invent just a
little box that reheats your food right
like you eating something get hulk cold
right and then you just make a [ __ ]
uh you know you put in the fridge and
it's cold right it saves it it saves the
food for you right but then what do you
want to do when you want to heat it up
you don't want to use the oven you guys
can make a little box man just plug it
right in
that's a microwave
it's so funny these [ __ ] stars that
are just so gone dude like if you ask
matthew mcconaughey hey how much is a
gallon of milk he'd probably be like
like 42 dollars i think
i don't know what's a gallon
who's milk
what who is milk
like dude
also is he morphing into a [ __ ]
afghan hound
his hair you know it's so flattened down
it's unbelievable but he's got soda in
his voice doesn't he man you could
listen him talk about today i would love
to see matthew mcconaughey's to-do list
didn't he write a book and like half the
book was blank pages for you to write oh
dude
a crook
stealing money here's blank pages man
here's your to-do list
he did it he does the voice and sing
and sing is a movie that i tried
watching with my son i fell asleep
though and then when i woke up he was
like he had he had his [ __ ] diaper
off and he was just talking about poop
but he didn't but i was like okay so
he's not watching i'm falling asleep so
okay
um
crazy [ __ ] world we live in man you
know it's interesting uh the
that social media has just really like
exposed how corny everybody is if that's
their thing like some people are
actually cool right but some people just
like it shows the the social media uh is
just like you're like oh like i don't
think like harrison ford is not on
social media right but if he was you
might be like oh
oh this guy's a loon
by the way how could he not be a loon
right the guy's [ __ ] uh the blade
runner guy he's the star wars guy han
solo he's the [ __ ] uh uh i mean he's
the fugitive he's he's he's this guy's
an icon how could you not be dude the
fact that these stars you know what
props to matthew mcconaughey for real
the guy won a [ __ ] oscar he's in
iconic movies the dude killed it in all
of like some movies some movies he's
horrible in like sahara but but dude the
guy kills it in a time to kill the guy
kills it in a [ __ ] uh interstellar
even though that movie made no sense and
he kills it in um the dallas buyers club
i mean the guy can is capable of killing
it
but like
he's an icon
so to not become a lunatic and not
absolutely take an ak-47
into different rooms and just start
spraying props off dude
because you must think in jesus christ
you know we do we just get a book wake
up put a book next to your bed you know
put a little box next to your bed we'll
call that a night table okay we'll call
that a night table and then we'll put a
little light bulb hook it up to some
electricity we'll call that a lamp okay
what you can do is you can make a
[ __ ] end table and make what i call a
lamp put a book on it with empty pages
and that'll be your to-do list okay
that's what we're gonna call in that
write down fun things
write down fun things write down your
favorite movie what that's not to do and
then you just wake up and just cross it
off be like yup that's my favorite movie
just write cheese
cheese just write cheese for number five
what and then just cross it off whenever
you think of cheese the next morning
even if it's just gouda or whatever
you think of gowdy you just cross it off
man it's fun
what a life you know
just [ __ ] always so far deep in his
backyard and his wife's just like where
the [ __ ] is matthew mcconaughey
there he is looking and he's got a vest
on just crossing off [ __ ] on a [ __ ]
loose leaf
did that one
cheese just thought of cheese sweetheart
[Laughter]
just okay honey good that's great can we
just can we refer you can refurnish
whatever you want let me just write it
down so we can cross it off when it's
done make sure it's fun
can you bring more hair gel i'm trying
to actually turn into an afghan hand
um so yeah so he did that and that was
absolutely [ __ ] killer dude you know
what's awesome about this lately two
days in a row my contact's so blurry i
ass dude my contacts are blurry no
matter what took them out put on
different contacts and yes they're
blurry still no matter what happens dude
that's so [ __ ] dope dude i can't see
[ __ ] it's awesome
people go
i mean my wife was trying to show me
something on her phone and i just
couldn't see it and i got she's like
isn't that crazy and i just go yup
couldn't see it she has no idea she
probably won't even hear this so i got
out of it you know what i mean but what
if it was something important i don't
know maybe my contacts aren't it's this
one day i woke up put them in i don't
know maybe it's a bad batch i don't know
man is this even interesting i don't
give a [ __ ] i love you guys man
you guys feel me people tell me to do
the [ __ ] laser surgery and it's like
or the lasik surgery and it's like dude
i i understand it works and i understand
it came out in like 2004 and it's way
better now and it's way cheaper now and
it's manageable but hey how about this
dude i don't want lasers shot in my eyes
and that's an old head thing but that's
who i am and i'm an old head okay
because uh
what if i sneeze when it's going going
down you know just [ __ ]
you just sit there and they give you a
xanax you put the ticket to [ __ ] zany
island you're there and like okay don't
move and you're like okay cool the laser
just comes on the [ __ ] thing and
you're like i chew
and then you're just brain falls out
oh my god did you sneeze we had a
sneezer
i chewed you don't slice my tongue in
half
ha
ha look man just write that down man
write down your tongue split in half and
then just cross it out cause it's
already done
write down brain matter that it spilled
out didn't it just cut it just
just
just cross it out brain matter look
right there wake up number one you
already did that cross that out number
two
favorite you drink drink coffee cut that
great brain matter fell out just slide
that out to cross it off man look at
that wear my favorite shirt good cross
that off oh look at this one number five
tongue split in half cross head up look
at this one look six blood all over my
favorite shirt just cross that out
you're already done with that
hurry up keep crossing them out you're
about to die man you want to die with a
full list no way
no way crazy
crazy
crazy
crazy
[Music]